uh folks we really
gotta talk about trisha paytas
hey everyone i'm abby sharpe welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by skillshare
and we're going to be looking at a
controversial personality and veteran
youtuber
trisha paytas now before we get too far
into things i want to chat about what
i've been learning through my skillshare
membership while social distancing at
home
so if you haven't heard of skillshare
they are an amazing
online learning community with a wide
range of
awesome creative classes for exploring
new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity
now i know a lot of people might be
thinking about ways to
learn some new skills and diversify
their careers
especially in these uncertain coveted
times
so as a creator i've been taking
creativity unleashed
discover hone and share your voice
online
by youtuber nathaniel drew this has been
so valuable for helping me determine my
value
overcome insecurities establish my voice
and evolve as i grow so whether you're
bored
need some extra self-care or want to
join a creative community
while in isolation skillshare is a great
resource during these times
and of course beyond and for my
followers the first 1000 people to click
the link
will get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
and after that it's only around 10 a
month
okay so before we get into the
nitty-gritty you can check out my
disclaimer here on screen
so feel free to pause the video to read
it or you can check it out
in the description below also a huge
trigger warning here folks if you have
battled or are battling disordered
eating
please sit this one out i have limited
the clips that i'm showing for this
reason alone but in general
it could be really triggering also
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right let's be real trisha paytas
is a pretty interesting bird
she has been on youtube since mid-2000s
which i mean
did we even have youtube then but to
summarize her succinctly
she's often described as a textbook
definition of a youtube troll
there is nothing but contradictions and
sensationalism
on any one trisha paytas video
at times she has claimed to be
transgender which got her in some hot
water
with the lgbtq community and has also
said that she has multiple personalities
which
also caused some uproar for creating
misinformation about dissociative
identity disorder
now obviously i do not know trisha
personally or professionally
and i'm not here to deny that these
things are valid and true
but i only mention them to point out
some of the controversy
that has really followed trisha and her
content
what i do want to focus on of course is
trisha's diet
and her relationship with food and
really how that has evolved over time
now if we looked at trisha's channel
from about a year ago we'll see
back to back episodes of her trialing
some pretty extreme fad diets
so she did the five day water fast
cleanse where she consumed well
just water she did an egg diet where she
actually ended up
gaining weight eating only eggs and she
did the joker diet where she ate
an entire head of iceberg lettuce now i
have
thankfully heard her add a disclaimer
that she does these diet videos mainly
for entertainment purposes
and that she doesn't expect to keep
weight off in the long run
doing something as extreme as an egg
fast
but then she kind of negates her this is
all for funsies attitude
by talking about how she just really
needs to lose weight
so it's probably not really clear what
her intentions are
and a disclaimer like that is not going
to do much
when the influencer then goes on to
focus on her weight loss goals
but anyways let's listen to what she has
to say about her approach
to losing weight i think people who are
not overweight don't really understand
that we have to get this initial
weight off right so like moderation
moderation which i do agree but you kind
of have to do a little bit more of
extreme
calorie counting or i'm kind of doing
more or less this diet to kind of get
a little bit more of a head start for i
don't i didn't want to just like
throw away this week completely you know
you can have an off day
it off week but especially when you've
come
through like two months you're like
there's no turning back
i'm not gonna just completely gain it
all but no no i am going down
every single month okay so a few
thoughts on trisha's weight loss
approach
first of all i am all for flexibility
and the message that
it's all about the long game if you
break your diet on the weekend or have
an
off week of eating because it's a
holiday or if you've gone traveling
then it doesn't mean all is lost it
doesn't have to be
all or nothing it's a long game
so i think it does make sense that
trisha said she's you know getting a
head start on her diet
and doesn't want to waste this week even
though she knows she's going to be
off her diet or eating maybe less
healthy things when she goes back home
over the weekend
most importantly this typical yo-yo
dieting is obviously quite detrimental
to your relationship with food
mental health and physical health but it
also doesn't serve to support one's
weight loss efforts either now trigger
warning
i am going to talk numbers but assuming
that weight loss
were a strict numbers game which
newsflash
it's not but if it was and you were
theoretically
to put yourself in a caloric deficit of
let's say 300 calories a day
monday through thursday that's a 1200
calorie
deficit in a week and then if you over
eat by
500 calories friday saturday and sunday
you're only up 300 calories that whole
week
so sure it might slow down your weight
loss
but it's really not a big deal
especially if you're able to see it as
not a big deal
and let it spiral you into a prolonged
binge
now trisha did say this but of course
trisha is also the queen of
contradiction because in a more recent
video where she was eating
korean fried cheese she says it's my
last day on november 1st i'm trying to
diet for real because i'm having music
videos in december
and um yeah so i'm like this is my like
last craving week of stuff
this my friends is what we call the last
supper mentality and more than anything
this is the reason
why going on these extreme diets in the
first place
really does not make sense it's the idea
that
hey you know the diet starts tomorrow so
i gotta get in all the forbidden foods
right now back to trisha's diet videos
for a sec because
i do want to relate my earlier comments
to her specifically
now in tricia diets she's not putting
herself in a 300 calorie deficit and
then overeating 500 calories on the
weekends
she's literally not eating and then
doing like a mukbang like binge so
obviously for some people
even modest caloric restriction is going
to trigger a binge
but when you're not eating or eating
like just
eggs obviously your body is going to
rebel
now if she were to not put herself on an
extremely restrictive diet like the egg
diet or water fast in the first place
she probably wouldn't need to overeat
when she went away on a vacation for
example
or realistically at least not to an
uncomfortable level
without that feeling of mental scarcity
and also physical deprivation
it's easier to eat the foods you love in
moderation
now i recognize that this may be easier
said than done especially for those with
a history of dieting
and restriction like trisha but this
recommendation
is really kind of just for the general
population who are watching videos like
hers
and also who are watching mine now
trisha also mentioned that people like
her
need to take on these really extreme
diets to kind of kick start their weight
loss
before they can reach a maintenance mode
i respectfully disagree
taking on too much too fast is the most
reliable road
to throwing in the towel on any health
promoting behaviors
not that a water fast or an egg diet is
what i would call a healthy diet
but you know what i mean research also
suggests that this weight cycling
is arguably more dangerous than staying
at one's original
higher weight as yo-yo dieting does
increase the risk of diabetes
and metabolic syndrome abdominal obesity
heart disease
general life dissatisfaction and other
mental health concerns
case in point over the past year we've
seen a departure from trisha's kind of
weight loss content
to daily mukbang uploads
she's literally become the poster child
of the mukbang
and it's almost always not on
particularly healthy
or balanced foods so from korean fried
cheese to donuts to mac and cheese to
taco bell nachos
most of these meals take place in the
car with a camera
and maybe a few friends now you guys
know my thoughts on mukbangs in general
i have a whole video where i discuss my
concerns
but in short i think what started out as
people wanting to build a community for
solo diners
looking for company at mealtimes has
basically become
a glorified binge on otherwise
restricted
foods now while other youtubers i've
reviewed like nicocado avocado and
amberlynn reed
have both come out saying that they do
the mukbang format largely for views
because that's what people watch most i
haven't heard the same from trisha but
of course it's very possible i missed
that from her
honestly there's so much content on her
channel
and each video is like 30 to 90 minutes
long
most of which is her chewing so yeah
it's
a lot to digest but in her most recent
videos
i did hear evidence of her current
relationship with food status
and honestly it didn't look good
let's take a look painting weight loss
right
which i'm going to get back to i just
talked to my trainer today and i'm like
getting back to it if i eat once a day
even if it's not a great meal like even
if it's pizza i tend to stay the same
weight the next day
and if you eat around this time which is
like what time is it like three
thirty feet around three thirty you
start getting like a little hungry and
then your hunger always subsides in the
morning right like if you go to bed like
i'm hungry you're fine in the morning
for the most part
and then i can usually kind of wait
again and if i can't wait i need to have
something around like
11 or something i have like a little
mini cliff bar but i try and wait till 3
30 then it's like worth it and then
i don't know it's helped me like
maintain my weight i don't know it's not
the best thing it's definitely not the
healthiest but
okay so interestingly trisha
acknowledges that a lot of her
methods that she uses for weight loss
aren't necessarily very healthy
but she continues to try them out
because like she said
it's worked now it's really unfortunate
to me that she feels that she needs to
put herself to bed hungry
and push herself to ignore those innate
primal cues every day
by forcing herself to eat only one meal
and as evidenced in some of her videos
shot while intermittent fasting
usually she can't actually keep it up
usually she ends up eating like a whole
other large meal
which only makes sense because her body
is probably
screaming at her for more food
so while i appreciate that in her video
she often offers that disclaimer that
you know she's not a nutritionist
or not making diet suggestions she's
just sharing what she's doing or what
works for her
i still do think that she needs to be
held accountable here
like as i always say as an influencer
i believe that we need to take
responsibility
for the content that we put out there
and
suggesting that we eat one meal a day
and
go to bed hungry because the hunger will
subside in the morning
can be really triggering for a lot of
vulnerable
viewers let's see what else she has to
say
i wanted to share my first bite of ice
cream with you guys
baskin robbins is so good i'm very
addicted to it
i look insane i kind of had a bad day so
i went and got some korean fried cheese
i
really don't like i like hang onto
things if i have a bad day it like
i hang on to it and i just thought i
deserved some korean fried cheese today
so that's what i got
okay so i have discussed the science of
food addiction ad nauseam on my channel
here
and while the jury is out on its
legitimacy from a
biophysiological or clinical perspective
i'm not denying its possibility or at
least the
feeling or experience of food addiction
being
very real what i can tell you however
is that the media loves to talk about
the mice research suggesting that sugar
is as addictive as cocaine because it
causes symptoms of withdrawal
but if you look at the research
carefully what this actually says
is that the subjects aka mice
only displayed addictive or
withdrawal-like behaviors
after they had been previously
restricted of sugar
in other words when you make sugar a
novelty you're going to obsess
so when you are yo-yo dieting
restricting yourself to just like
one meal eating only eggs or otherwise
somehow feeling deprived
it seems totally normal to have these
food
obsessive-like tendencies it also
appears to me that trisha may be relying
heavily on eating as a coping mechanism
for dealing with some negative emotions
now it's totally normal to occasionally
eat emotionally
we all do it from time to time and that
doesn't mean that you are
failing at eating intuitively as long as
it doesn't trigger
a cycle of guilt and shame however
when food becomes our only coping
strategy
that's when it's likely time to try to
get to the root of the issue
and find some more effective strategies
and
usually that involves actual therapy not
another diet
so obviously we don't watch trisha for
healthy eating advice
and i think it's quite clear that even
with her diet videos
she's usually transparent about them not
being
health-promoting behaviors with the
exception of her water fasting video
where she did attempt
to list some of the supposed benefits
but what i
do take issue with above all else is
trisha messing with a very
vulnerable subject of her following and
that
is those currently struggling or those
with a history of disordered eating
and eating disorders let me explain so
i was scrolling through tik tok which is
one of my absolute
least favorite pastimes of life and i
saw that trisha had a message
for her fans struggling with eating
disorders
let's take a look hi my name is trish
and today i'm going to be having a donut
as
a snack if you're having trouble eating
your breakfast lunch dinner
snack or food in general today i want to
take my first bite with you and
hopefully you'll take your first bite
with me
so cheers one more tic talk for the day
i actually really like alicia marie i
just wanted to make a public service
announcement since my last
video was garnered to people who suffer
with
eating disorders where they have trouble
eating food keeping food down et cetera
i too have struggled with ed
um i know a lot of people you don't look
like it but it's actually a binge eating
disorder that i had
to seek treatment for and anyways this
thumbnail was triggering to a lot of
people and i'm just here to remind you
that no food should make you ever feel
guilty we need food to nourish our
bodies
and some people may disagree with what
goes in our bodies whether you eat fast
food or meat or you're vegan or whatever
people are always going to disagree with
what goes in your body but as long as
you're feeding yourself
every food is guilt-free food don't ever
feel guilty
don't ever forgo for these gimmicks your
body deserves food and energy and fuel
and i hate things like this guilt-free
it's such a bad message to stand young
girls so
sending this out to whoever needs to
hear it don't feel guilty about eating
food
so what's wrong with this picture
no it's not that she's eating a donut
because trisha eats donuts often
and that's cool with me no it's not that
she's saying that she thinks every food
should be
guilt-free food i think that's actually
a really great message and one that i
fully support
but it's that she's literally calling on
the eating disorder community
bringing this vulnerable population in
calling this a safe space and then
spamming these folks with mukbangs and
restrictive diet videos
both of which could be incredibly
triggering for somebody in recovery
or actively suffering from disordered
eating
this is not okay
so to tease this issue apart a little
bit more i want to bring back
my friend eating disorder dietitian
alessandra magisano
to discuss some of these major themes
so thanks for joining me alexandra oh
thank you i'm so happy to be back thank
you
so i want to talk about how restriction
and binging are actually so
intrinsically linked
but obviously recovery is not as simple
as just like eating guilt-free food like
trisha suggested so
for example eating donuts or having like
a book bag or something like that
isn't necessarily evidence of recovery
absolutely when we think about
binging and restricting being so
intrinsically linked
we usually talk about it in reference to
food
and although that's very important and
it's usually a the case when we're
talking about disorder eating
relationships
food is used as a vehicle um as a kobe
strategy
it's not about food so the binging and
the restricting of
food is not the cause
is not the whole um value of what it
means to have an eating disorder so if
we say just eat guilt-free food
these kinds of things are really
dangerous because it again undermines
that an eating disorder is
not about food and what you just do with
food behaviorally
it's the brain chemistry that's involved
in what it means to have an eating
disorder and that
somebody can't just eat
guilt-free food and it'll just fix them
like that there's so much
more involved and it's dangerous to
watch something
that that's just oh eat guilt-free food
and think okay well then i can be cured
just but that it puts the onus on the
food
rather than what actually eating
disorders are about that they're complex
they're layered um and it also makes it
feel like you can't seek out
professional support or
um seek individual support from your
physicians and from you know your
your care team because if you can just
eat guilt-free food then anybody can
cure themselves
people who are suffering let's say from
a restrictive um
eating disorder can easily kind of like
waffle into more binging territory and
back and forth so
can you discuss a little bit more about
that absolutely so if somebody who's
you know you can swing back and forth
because a lot of the times
actually i would say all of the time
the symptoms of pinching and restricting
happen on a spectrum
and so it's not just one um and they
kind of go in and out
and so if you start out more restrictive
you can kind of
in other ways introduce some binge-like
um
behaviors even without food like
sometimes we think about binging and
restricting only in regards to food but
the truth is they happen
in other ways with other things in our
life
other substances um and so
you kind of if you're restricting in
food you might be binging somewhere else
and not necessarily have that link and
think oh well like but i'm not binging
on food so what's what's the issue but
you might actually be
somewhere else and then the pendulum is
always going to swing because you're
always on a spectrum nobody just stays
in one
space of restricting and binging it's
like up and down and all around
um right and not to mention like whether
or not that
donut that you you know ate guilt-free
is that going to lead you right back
into a restrictive episode
you know the next day or whatever so
that's right that's right
that's right i mean it could be part of
the rules too like i i know lots of
eating disorders and i've heard lots of
stories that you know that
that there's permissible rules in within
eating disorders that let you
behave seemingly normal with food
but are completely disordered in their
own way so that's why when you see
things like oh i can eat guilt-free food
you might because that's that's in in
your box that feels
safe but it's all within the context of
eating disorders so i think
this topic is really important because
viewers have to know
that the things they see might actually
be
part of somebody's um
journey with disordered eating where
they're presenting it as
the solution when in fact it's
part of the disorder that is a really
good point because it's something that i
see
um with this book bang trend on youtube
a lot is that
you know a lot of fitness influencers
they they restrictly restrict
they restrict and then they have a
mukbang and that's you know
kind of alleged evidence of them having
a good relationship with food or a
balanced relationship with food but like
you said
that is built into their set of that
their set of
of weekly rules that they know that if
they restrict heavily enough
all week long they can have that cheat
meal and it's not going to
you know it's not going to tip the
scales too much so they can that's that
they're allowed to do that
as long as they get back right right
back onto that restrictive bandwagon
on monday or whatever it is so exactly
good
really good point okay well thank you so
much alessandra you are always such a
wealth of knowledge
i will of course be leaving links to
alessandra's instagram and contact
information below so that you can reach
out if you're looking for some
one-on-one support
thank you guys so much now in conclusion
i can't think of a lot of channels on
youtube that i think are
more problematic than trisha paytas um
i actually think trisha is pretty honest
in her intentions
most of the time like when she tries out
an outrageous diet for entertainment
or spends a full week uploading mukbangs
in full-on costume
this content is not really meant to
teach you something it's
pretty much out there for entertainment
and for shock value
i mean i guess you could say it's
trolling one-on-one
but when she starts to offer
pseudo-wellness advice to an
already very vulnerable population and
then juxtapose that against a backdrop
of her own problematic eating episodes
that is where she crosses a line
so if you are struggling or have
struggled with disordered eating
or your relationship with food i would
avoid trisha's channel
at all cost and on that note that is all
that i have today for you folks
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen
bye